Speaker 1: Let's go to Omar from Atlanta. Omar
from Atlanta, welcome to the program. What is
on your mind today?
Speaker 2:
Hello? Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Yes. So I think the other Atlanta
gentleman had a similar question. It's kind
of about the Trump indictment recently on these
documents. So my question is, is that especially
since the Espionage Act has been used to prosecute
people, at least the left would assume to be
heroes like reality winner and whatnot. First
of all, what are your thoughts on the hypocrisy
of reality? Winner from the moment of arrest to
being released, never saw foot outside of jail
and the hypocrisy there with Trump. And secondly,
on whether or not we should be cheering on the
Espionage Act to be used against Trump like this.
Speaker 1: I don't have any. Philosophical
opposition to it being used. I. It
is not unique that statutes and law.
Can be used in ways we don't agree with. That is
that's not that's not a unique thing. And that
alone doesn't make me say this is suspect, this is
bad, or whatever the case may be. We are we just
got the indictment. We are eventually going to see
what this case is built on and we're all going to
be able to sort of judge for ourselves whether
the espionage is correct or incorrect. Now,
I think it's important to say Trump is not
accused of spying for another country. A
lot of people are hearing the word espionage
or Espionage Act and assuming certain things
that are not actually part of the indictment,
let's not allow the word. I mean, the Espionage
Act contains a number of different provisions. If
the indictment is accurate, Trump did violate the
Espionage Act doesn't mean he spied for Russia.
So I think it's way too certainly too early to
say it's incorrect to charge him in that way.
Speaker 2: Right. Yeah, He he's charged with
improperly holding documents, not sharing
them. Yeah, I guess from my perspective,
it's because we have that Georgia case building
up right now. I would much prefer to see that in
the limelight than Espionage Act violations,
which just seems at least personally less
tenuous from a political perspective.
Speaker 1: There's also a number of
different charges, and it's obstruction and
it's a whole bunch of different things. And
it's also a false notion to say the only thing
Trump did wrong was having the documents. It
actually goes much further than that. And in
fact, this is the point why you have to look
at what Hillary was was investigated for. To
understand it's not about holding documents.
Speaker 2: And refusing to return them.
Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, that's fair.
Speaker 1: All right. Omar from
Atlanta, thank you for the call.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Very,
very direct question. I like that. Why don't
we go next to Zach from New York? Zach,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hi, David. Thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Speaker 2: So my question for you is, which
political figure do you think has the biggest
differential between how serious they appear
versus how big of a clown they actually are?
Speaker 1: Let me think about this. The bigger
and it could be. It could be that they are
more or less serious than their than their
public perception. Right. It could be either way.
Speaker 2: I guess so. But I'm more interested
in who appears to be very serious,
what is actually a very big clown.
Speaker 1: You know, Mitch McConnell comes to
mind both his seniority and his confidence in
answering even about things he has no clue on
make him seem extremely serious to many people.
And I think that at the end of the day, he
actually is a total clown. So so McConnell
comes to mind. I'm trying to think who else.
You know, the thing about Trump is he's not
serious and he doesn't seem serious. So it's
like it's very obviously not Trump, you know?
Speaker 2: You can spot that clown a mile away.
Speaker 1: You know, maybe Pence would be in the
running because especially next to Trump,
Pence seemed so sober and serious. But
his beliefs are just built on crumbling
trash, you know, just a dumpster fire.
So I would put Pence in the running as well.
Speaker 2: Okay. I like that answer. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Well, thank you, Zach. I
appreciate it. Zach from New York, that is it is
actually a tough question when you don't think
about it super, super specifically. All right,
everybody, let's take a break. We will take more
calls again, if I have anything to say about it.